and almost morning
in noon
thank you for being here
yesterday marked
11 months since Russia's brutal full
scale invasion of Ukraine and 11 months
in which Ukrainian people have showed
Putin and the world
the full force of their courage and the
abdominal determination to live free
and through every single step this is a
horrific War the American people have
been strong and unwavering their support
and Democrats and Republicans in
Congress have stood together
the United States has worked in lockstep
with our allies and partners around the
world to make sure you're the Ukrainian
people are in the strongest possible
position to defend their Nation their
families and against the brutal the
truly brutal aggression of Russia I
haven't seen the likes of this in a long
time
the United States and Europe are fully
United
this morning
I had a long conversation with our NATO
allies German Chancellor Schultz friends
president macron prime minister Sanuk
and the Italian Prime Minister Maloney
uh to continue our close coordination
and our full supported Ukraine because
you all know I've been saying this for a
long time the expectation of the part of
Russia is we're going to break up we're
not going to stay United but we are
fully thoroughly totally United
with spring approaching Ukrainian forces
are working to defend the territory they
hold and preparing for additional
counter offenses
to liberate their land they need to be
able to counter Russia's evolving
tactics and strategy on the battlefield
in the very near term
they need to improve their ability to
maneuver and open Terrain
and they need an enduring capability to
deter and defend against Russian
aggression over the long term
the Secretary of State the secretary of
the uh
the military behind me are they they've
been deeply deeply involved in this this
whole effort armored capability as
general Austin will tell you to speak
out of there
is has been has been critical that's why
the United States has committed hundreds
of armored fighting vehicles to date
including more than 500 as part of the
assistance package we announced last
Friday
and today today I'm announcing that the
United States will be sending 31 Abram
tanks to Ukraine the equivalent of one
Ukrainian Battalion secretary Austin has
recommended this step because it will
enhance the Ukraine's capacity to defend
its territory and achieve its strategic
objectives the Abram's thanks are the
most capable tanks in the world and
they're also extremely complex to
operate and maintain
so we're also giving Ukraine the parts
and equipment necessary to effectively
sustain these tanks on the battlefield
when we begin we'll begin to train the
Ukrainian troops on these issues of
sustainment logistics and maintenance
soon as possible
delivering these tanks to the field is
going to take time
time that we'll see and we'll use to
make sure the ukrainians are fully
prepared to integrate the Abram tanks
into their defenses
we're also closely coordinated this
announcement with our allies
the American contribution will be joined
by an additional announcement including
that will be will be ready to available
and more easily integrated for use in
the battlefield in the coming weeks and
months from other countries I'm grateful
of Chancellor Schultz for providing
German Leopard two tanks and will lead
an effort to organize a European
contribution of two tank battalions for
Ukraine
I want to thank the chancellor for his
leadership and his steadfast commitment
to our Collective efforts to support
Ukraine
Germany has really stepped up the
chancellor has been a strong strong
voice for Unity a close friend and for
the level of effort we're going to
continue
supporting Ukraine's ability to fight
off Russian aggression to defend its
sovereignty and territorial Integrity is
a worldwide commitment
just looks a worldwide commitment last
week Germany and Germany secretary
Austin convened Ukraine defense contact
group for the eighth time this group is
made up of some 50 Nations 50 Nations
each making significant contribution of
their own to Ukraine's integrity
he's fully committed to making Ukraine
remain strong and independent and able
to defend itself against Russian threats
and violence
I want to thank every member of that
Coalition for continuing to step up
the UK the United Kingdom recently
announced that it's donating Challenger
2 tax to Ukraine France is contributing
AMX 10s armor inviting vehicles
in addition to the leopard tanks the
Germany like the United States is also
Germany is also sending a pet a patriot
missile battery the Netherlands is
donating to Patriot missile and
launchers France Canada the UK Slovakia
and Norway and others have all donated
critical air defense systems to help
secure Ukrainian skies and save the
lives of innocent civilians who are
literally the target
the target of Russia's aggression
Poland is sending armored vehicles
Sweden is donating infantry fighting
Vehicles Italy is giving artillery
Denmark and Estonia are sending
howitzers Latvia is providing more
Stinger missiles lithuanians providing
anti-aircraft guns and Finland recently
announced his largest package of
security assistance a day you may
remember I was asked a while ago what I
think was going to happen and I said I
wouldn't know he thought that he's going
to end up with a fennelization of Europe
where he's got the natoization of
Finland we've got something that he
never intended together with our allies
and partners we sent more than 3 000
armored vehicles
where the 8 000 artillery systems more
than two million rounds of artillery
ammunition and more than 50 Advanced
multi-launch rocket systems anti-ship
and air defense systems all to help
counter
Ukraine's brutal aggression
that's happening because of Russia
and look today's announcement Builds on
the hard work and commitment from
countries around the world led by the
United States of America to help Ukraine
defend its sovereignty as territorial
integrity
that's what this is about helping
Ukraine defend and protect Ukrainian
land it is not an offensive threat to
Russia you know there is no offensive
threat to Russia if Russia troops
returned to Russia they'll be there
where they belong this war would be over
today
that's what we all want an end of this
war
in just and Lasting terms
you know our teams do not permit One
Nation we're not going to allow one
nation to steal our neighbors to
territory by force
our terms that preserve Russia's
Sovereign Ukrainian sovereignty and
territorial integrity and honor the U.N
Charter that's our the terms we're
working on
and you know these are these are the
terms we all signed up for and 143
Nations voted for in the United Nations
General Assembly last October so the
United States standing shoulder to
shoulder allies and partners is going to
continue to do all we can to support
Ukraine
Putin expected Europe and the United
States to weaken our resolve he expected
our support for Ukraine to crumble with
time
he was wrong he was wrong he was wrong
from the beginning he continues to be
wrong we are united
America's United and so is the world
we approach the one-year Mark as we do
of the Russian full-scale invasion
Ukraine we remain United and determined
as ever and our conviction and our cause
these tanks are further evidence of our
enduring unflagging commitment to
Ukraine and our confidence and the skill
of the Ukrainian forces
as I told president zielinski when he
was here and today is his birthday by
the way
in December we're with you for as long
as it takes Mr President
Cravings are fighting an age-old battle
against aggression and domination
it's a battle Americans have fought
proudly time and again
and it's the battle we're going to make
sure the ukrainians are well equipped to
fight as well this is about freedom
freedom for Ukraine
Freedom everywhere it's about the kind
of world we want to live in the world we
want to leave to our children
so may God protect the brave Ukrainian
Defenders of their country
keep the flame of Liberty Burning
Brightly as it can thank you Mr
President why are you taking this
decision now
the Germany forced you to change your
mind on sending things
Germany didn't force me to change your
mind we wanted to make sure we're all
together as we're going to do all and
that's what we're doing right now thank
you Mr President any response to the
Pence disclosures and classified
documents
Sarah the searches of your homes
completed Mr President when is Jeff Zion
starting as your next Super staff will
you search for hobet